thank you for inviting me and thank you
everyone for joining and for attending
the talks so I'm foods that come from
Polytechnic in Montreal
well with my team we have been focusing
recently on quality assurance of machine
learning enable systems right so the
goal of the research we're trying to do
is to allow you guys and the community
to design and build reliable machine
learning based systems and we all know
that with this new specificity of the
system with the dependency of the data
there are much more issues that comes up
with the
nature so we are trying to tackle off
those issues on benett's issue related
to data quality issues on the
specifications
implementations and and so on so today I
will give you a glimpse of some of the
things we have been doing so machine
learning AIDS have been ready for prime
time so I've been already deploying many
systems I am in the room I'm pretty sure
most of us have been using some of those
of those systems but they need to be
reliable
and typically to produce the model that
we embed in the systems we actually do
produce a lot of codes right so this is
a typical pipeline for a deep learning
systems where you have to
produce code to fetch your data to
automate the learning process and then
you have to train you have to test
validate until you can deploy so all
through this process we actually writing
codes
to actually generate models and then as
any type of programs they often fails
and they fail a bit differently from
what we do in what we see in the
traditional programs so contrary to
traditional programs the space of
failures for those system is a bit more
broader right so you can have issues
related to
modeling process so you can have a lot
of under specification issues and then
we also have implementation issues
because we have to actually script all
the code that actually automate the
learning process and we have many issues
with data quality right so we need to
actually be able to detect those issues
and what I'm trying to share with you is
some of the tools that we have been
building to help with this because we
believe that only automation can
actually help going through this process
right if you have been trying to play
with some model you can know that
debugging a machine learning pipeline
can be actually very tricky because
sometimes the difference between a
state-of-the-art model and a very poor
performing model can be as simple as the
learning rates right so it's very
difficult to actually find those knobs
when you try to trick the model so we
try to automate this so what do we do
so we in this talk I will talk about two
approach that we propose one it's based
on stacking and static analysis so we
brought static analysis to the problem
why we thought about this because then
we all know that it's quick right it's a
bit cheaper and it can be very effective
if it's done correctly upfront so we
have a tool that we built which is
neural lens which is actually pretty
effective and I actually encourage you
to try it out right so the tool can
actually have been tested so you have
the decay in the paper I won't talk
about the detail in the paper but what I
can say it's more how the tool works so
how did we build the tools so the tool
rely on two key components so we have a
meta model of the learning program that
we had to build right and then we also
had a taxonomy of typical faults in a
deep learning program so in the tool we
basically automate the detection of this
Force based on the representation of a
deep learning program that we built
based on this meta model right simple
right okay so the workflow looks like
this so if you have a program and then
you want to use our tool basically
basically what we do is that we extract
from your program all the different
features and components that we need to
comply with the specification of the
meta model then we built a
representation of your program
and then based on our set of rules that
we actually specify to detect the
different issues we can actually run
detections on the program and provides a
set of checks
and it works and it's pretty fast okay
but the problem with this is that this
with static analysis we can't really
tackle the interaction with the data and
the dynamicity that's in the process
right so to help with that aspect we
try something else that we all do
Dynamic analysis right so we decided to
actually
export what do you do we decide to
inspect the training process of the
program and extract information about
the behavior of the program during the
training process and based on this
information we could actually check
certain specific property we could be
signal of problem with the training
model right so we have this approach
which it's also pretty effective we have
been compared actually with sagemaker
which does a pretty similar thing and
the good news is that this approach does
a bit better so I actually encourage you
to try it out it can detect 30 more
backs than actually sagemaker we were
kind of forced to compare this for the
paper otherwise they wouldn't accept the
paper so what do some of the rules that
we actually rely on looks like so we the
tool Implement is a variety of checks
right so some of the checks can be as
simple as checking for parameter related
issues or are more complex optimization
related issues right so an example of
parameter related issue you can check
foreign Trend parameters and this is
very easy to change right so you can
extract information during the training
process and then just perform some
verifications right some
comprising
and then an example of activation
related issues so we can check the
ranges right so this is a common if you
have been trying deep learning problem
you can you know that this is something
that happened sometime very frequently
and then the two can actually report
this for you pretty easily right we also
have a lot of checks related to
optimization problems so you can check
if you are fitting the the data sample
for a while if you are having a
Vanishing gradients if you have an
unstable guidance and so on so all the
checks have been implementing the tool I
strongly encourage you to try out and
the flow is very simple so there is a
small overhead that comes with using the
tool because we're actually
instrumenting your process so we're
extracting information during the
training process so that is on overhead
that comes with that but through the
experimentation and validation that we
did the overages actually
stretchable manageable okay
so try the tools and that is it for me I
guess so um
so I wanted to raise your attention
about failures occurring frequently in
those systems and the fact that the
space of failure in this system is
actually pretty large compared to
traditional systems and that we actually
need automation to navigate this space
and hopefully these tools that we're
actually building and releasing will
actually help us to avoid those pitfalls
and maybe stay out of the float I think
this is from Mike
so any questions
so that's it